we're live are we live i'm not sure
any minute now we might be alone
are we like yeah skin stop it i'm gonna
get bam from twitch
goalie that's i feel like i can almost
see a nipple are we live
i don't know take it down now i think
that's a nipple on the left is it not
it's not a liverpool oh sorry are we
live yet
uh i don't know it doesn't really like
just work that quickly i never
exactly know if we're live let me check
we are
potentially well life yeah
yes that whole thing oh no you just did
it again i thought that it was like
replaying
but actually you were just [ __ ] doing
it again
all right hi everyone what's up uh
you're right loud
what's your problem uh this is a really
weird time to stream
it is 2 a.m but rahul and i
both happen to be awake and happen to
have work at 9 00 a.m
um and i thought that we would just do a
quick stream probably not very long we
both got our cups of tea for the record
pg tips good [ __ ]
um and i thought that i would have rahul
two of me around watch dogs legion i've
been playing the game like for a little
bit this week i've played a few hours
but um
actually haven't done many of the
content my current objectives in the top
left are because i'm supposed to be
uh recruiting an old lady instead
mate are you looking at your phone rahul
hey charlanazard is now live on twitch
okay that's all out uh do you know where
we are right now what is this
london yes but what specifically like i
feel like this little uh this is
actually pretty small
garden really it says sicilian avenue
no all right is it modeled on the real
city so i will
it is um i will go back over here
because this garden is [ __ ] beautiful
and i was like
is this a real place
i don't know you're supposed to tell me
this is supposed to be you telling me
where i am
russell's square are you familiar with
russell square
yeah yeah are you really or are you
lying
so this is russell square apparently any
thoughts coley
um it's almost like i've never been
there before it's crazy seeing a digital
digital
i guess what i'm looking for is does it
look
authentic it looks like it looks like a
yeah no it looks like a park for sure
it does definitely look like a park i
feel like
yeah so hang on if i pull up the map
what are you playing this on
this is on xbox one x to be precise i'm
actually not playing it on the series x
even though it should be compatible
right now wait i'm confused you're
playing it on what last generation's
machine
correct oh okay okay um
okay can you see the map even though the
fog of war is here
take me somewhere you uh
you want to go south what
go south you want me to go south yeah in
it
no no no no staff that's
is that a london accent yeah okay
okay then where do we want to go where
am i going here's this this is some sort
of river situation
it's got no names oh the thames is that
the thames yeah that's the thames
all right okay okay all right so that's
there's a large park over here
you see this yeah so go let's uh
go up high first so we like no the fog
of war is kind of [ __ ] it up is the
issue yeah can you go can you go on a
building
and we can look for landmarks and we can
head towards landmarks ooh
a good question we'll just go somewhere
uh okay i can try i can try yeah we can
see if i can do that i'm not actually
sure
if i can just [ __ ] hijack a building
from the jump
but let's take a look shall we how do i
get out of this park
park tv
is that what they say oh okay
does it make you don't have drones
um to the person in the chat uh this is
rahul
from blair manor yes who just asked
well is that what owen does in the show
coley is that why you've just done that
what i do now whenever someone shouts me
out or
you've become one of those have you
um okay i look you've
you've requested something that i didn't
really anticipate
which is that you want me to scale a
[ __ ] building for you
in this game that i've played you know a
couple of hours of i don't know
unlocked do you know every street in new
zealand
exactly yes yes i do as a matter of fact
okay my uncle is there right now because
he's a kiwi
um but you would think that this game
should have those like unlock points
that every ubisoft game has
of course is my i already know how to
play this game let me get without
looking
um you do something and scale it
and then it removes some of the fog uh
you can also
do side missions that after
doing your third resemble the other
like the rest of them that's fair
already
repeat this come to some kind of pub
situation is this really what this place
looks like this isn't accurate
we don't have cars like that in london
this is volatile there's no drones
either i don't know why i'm seeing so
many drones we even we haven't got that
many drones shit's changed since you've
been gone mate
drones everywhere how about this you
know i was there
wrong right you know i was there uh
this summer shit's changed okay we've
got drones that quick you gotta
see look at this little spider that you
got walking around your streets
how do you feel about that that's cool
it is excellent
it is actually pretty cool yes it's a
little insomniac
but the cops beat it up the last time
that i brought him out
the cops [ __ ] with my little spider
it's very upsetting
um okay euphemism the cops beat it up
they beat it up they beat up the spider
they beat him up
what acts are you doing what was that i
don't want to talk about it uh if we
could move on from that
that would be tight hey
also nice walk around wearing union
jacks on their shirts
if they're racist is really is that a
thing
yeah it's like a proper like bmp
like ukip nation like it's it's it's
it's the you're gonna need to break
those terms down for me
oh so uh it's it's our like right wing
the bmpu kip they used to be the the
british national party and they keep
rebranding obviously so
at one point i think they were the
national front and they were the bmp now
the uk
they always replace it's the same
ideology but they just keep changing the
name of the party
gotcha um we also have the edl yeah
okay um which i used to be a part of
or cdl english defense league
okay and what we do is
we are white and we want to keep
england white oh you're part of
the brexit squad well i was part of the
edl
i okay to keep england white
um and
that must have been i didn't a bit
conflicting for your family
when i went for my first meeting i
was immediately removed from the party
within about four seconds
why because
i i'd be the first to be gone why's that
it's brown i was setting you up for some
kind of joke and you just you just went
straight for the obvious answers that
brown in it
don't stream it two in the morning then
if you want comedy
do you know what i mean oh is this the
thing the british museum rahul you love
this place
yeah it's got egyptian thing it got
egyptian ting
hmm i can't get in uh still having
trouble scaling any kind of building
in there is it in the british yeah this
is what it looks like
are you happy i don't know i haven't
been since i was like seven great
okay you're not going to things i know
well what do you know and how do i get
there albeit
strip clubs okay where are they
i can't beat myself up like that
[Music]
we oh i think we might be in a in a
place called albion bro
we're not in a place called albion
brilliant
if it was if it was one of my mates if
it was like like moe i swear he used to
be a taxi driver or something he would
have been great oh i could get in a car
we'll save us some time if i [ __ ] get
in a vehicle you're still
still over here okay i'm still on this
[ __ ]
it looks like minority report yeah i
don't know what
uh era it's set in okay so boy said he
wanted me to go
south what's this little [ __ ] i5 or
towel here
what's that oh it was actually fabulous
square that's nelson's column what
no that's not your favorite square no i
guess we'll go there
okay are the streets this empty i feel
like i
picture london having the most crowded
streets in the [ __ ] universe
well we have a congestion charge now
we've had that for years what does that
mean
so there's a certain like set like
central london there's a
uh an area that once you enter
uh you have to pay to have your car in
that area as soon as you enter you have
to pay a congestion charge
[ __ ] myself i did that to myself by
accident
but um it doesn't look like london man
well it is set in the future i think um
everyone ignore that i got excited and
pressed a button
that actually just hurt me oh what's
canadian flag here for okay okay was i
wrong
was it trafalgar squares i don't know
son
you tell me i think i was right mate
uh yeah they it's stop stop stop stop
okay
awesome hold up get out get out get out
yep pull down the line
go to the lines turn right right
there you go and look up no to the left
[ __ ] me you're not good at this left
left left up
i've forgotten that your honor you're
seeing everything on a
about a second delay which is going to
make that kind of communication
difficult
who's who's nelson what he'd do hms
victory
what portsmouth come on what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you thought you were
smarter now what
no turns out we don't learn that
oh watergate yeah yeah familiar i've
heard about watergate
that was like a huge deal yeah that's
sick
see there we go so and i think the
tate's over there
i don't know it's pretty though whatever
it is i think that's i think nice to
take
is this is this thing on a crown or some
kind of real situation
yeah they have artwork they have art
installations around chicago square
i like how i say is this thing on a
crown some kind of real situation you go
yeah they got artwork in it
i said art installations they have art
installations outside of the gallery at
trafalgar square that is what it's
called
it says oh you're right there is only
just one a i'm sorry yep
i'm sorry it's better with this house is
that that's a tape right
um i don't know
is there a way to say anything is there
a landmark it says it's the national
national gallery national gallery
yeah isn't that the tape i don't know oh
god
where do you think i'm from well
i just i just upset loads of indians by
saying that i was british and i you know
i grew up in england and now i'm
embarrassing myself i should go back to
[ __ ] calcutta
go back to india mate uh all right so
so this is your national museum i
suppose what's what's trafalgar square
about like what's the situation what
kind of
square is just like uh it's it's um
it's just a square with the statute
yeah no you're nailing a landmark
remind me that if i ever go to london
that i make sure i don't go with you
i get myself a nice tour guide and
you're because you'd be like
yeah it's a square there's pigeons i
told you
nelson's column battle of waterloo
hms victory yes hms victory yes which is
in portsmouth
and um i said that there was an art
gallery there i told you just from
looking at the map i said i'm sure
that's that's
trafalgar square now from here
okay yeah take me somewhere do you want
to go leicester square piccadilly
no i would love to go to piccadilly all
right pull up the map
someone in chat said bruv simulator
2020.
all right we have map no
don't pull out that much i don't like
when i pull out that much
zoom zoom zoom zoom okay
all right yeah so here's where we are
right now bro the national gallery i
guess i can highlight things you know
oh the canadian high commission well
yeah this is for you to take me where i
you would like to take me where are we
going all right so
move up just look you just look just
hover around stuff and i'll tell you
what's cool to look at
i would have thought that you hey you
direct but all i'm saying
is that i think that maybe you should
pick a landmark you don't want to
find it all right then let's go to big
ben
okay big ben's gonna be on the train
yeah you're you're already okay it's the
latter night this is gonna be big ben
right here
i figured it out correct i don't [ __ ]
need you
okay so so what you want to do is
highlight
i thought i figured it out did i not is
that not big ben right there
i don't come to the [ __ ] outback and
tell you how to navigate king
is it okay is that not big men though
connected to the palace of westminster
yeah blood it's westminster
um houses of parliament the westminster
houses of parliament and i'll show you
from there
how to get to the national theater which
is where i
me should i take you to the do you want
to go to the bfi
imax to a place that little rahu did
some work oh brother i'd love to go to
the imax can we go to nando's after
that would be
on i am yes but i thought we were going
to
the westminster palaces first and then
you can find another
parliament the houses of parliament
is it somebody called you fake
englishman
that's bad all right all right all right
i'll tell you now so the national
gallery was there
um and if you wanted to go to [ __ ]
tea it's a good color
the best cup of tea for me
is with the milk and the bag
the the color of it has to resemble my
dick
that's the most egotistical thing i've
ever heard before in my life
yeah best taste you say you think your
own dick tastes good
too much milk is a little bit more
stronger
so i'll make it look like man
amazing wait i'm telling you okay
i think we should just do one thing at a
time i think we should go to big ben
first
and then we go to nellie's wine i'm not
hungry high commission is there
oh yeah we're near the new zealand we go
to the new zealand high commission mate
we could uh maybe stop by and they got
good wines for in new zealand okay
where are we going i'm going to big ben
you're going to big ben i love that i
have asked you to do this because we're
both awake
at two it's fine the in-game has that
and then what you have to do is you
[ __ ] you have to you have to use
google to figure it out oh i think i
made it already
oh yeah you're here that's big ben i
shouldn't have parked my car
here i'm sorry women drivers you
understand let me just park properly
right here notice what side of the road
you're driving do not do that that's uh
in between us bus wankers you need to
shout that every time you see a bus
football friend if you see people
waiting on the bus all right have a look
at big ben
now do you know that it's pretty big
it's all right but big ben isn't
actually the tower
what yeah it's the bell inside it it's
called big ben
i didn't know that so did you do oh
really was it not on your [ __ ] map
was it it probably is
i mean it is watchdogs i could probably
like if i could get info about
big ben or whatever no i can't yet it's
it is a restricted area though
it's so cool that like like this is my
favorite thing about any time that i
ever go
walking up the bridge keep walking on
the bridge in europe
is that you have like modern buildings
right next to the oldest most
gothic looking [ __ ] i've ever seen in my
life
like that on on steroids i would really
love to go to prague that would be tight
i shot a commercial there so i was out
there for like oh yes i shot a
commercial in prague
absolute [ __ ]
anyway yeah it was like it looked like
tim burton's batman buildings
and then a starbucks at the bottom of it
it was really weird the juxtaposition of
that when i went to paris for the first
time i went to paris to visit quantic
dream to talk about detroit to become
you see it's not as cool when i say it
that is why i went to paris though
um i went to the louvre
i think with my mum yeah and there's
just a starbucks and a [ __ ] apple
store
in the bottom did you not go inside yeah
we did
but the point is like the line was too
long
at least the mona lisa
yeah so your song you come out with it's
not a
cool tune yo so we're close to the uh
bfi
imax okay this is so pretty
that's my country my gosh
why does everything say albion on it i'm
wondering if that's like a corporate
thing right it's a corporate thing yeah
in-game corporate
and then you thought that yeah it's not
well you know i don't remind you of all
of your faces
is that how they look
my granddad london eye which means
you're next to the aquarium
is a brit and uh
the last like international trip that he
went on before he sadly passed away
shout out to derek grammer um was to
england
and he has the the my favorite photo of
him is him on a boat on the thames it's
like really really cute photo
because half my family is british and i
guess like the other half are basically
kiwis
on the rift sure i'll just tell you the
story about my dead granddad and you're
like yeah but there's fish in the
aquarium
i know but i do love aquariums
okay yeah i'm sorry granddad thank you
appreciate it
that's the aquarium what this
it is look at the fish yeah it's the
aquarium
so i'm giving you a proper tool
are these giant fish here in the real
aquarium
the giant whales i don't know if there's
whales anymore i think
that's pretty dope ah look a
soccer ball [ __ ]
i will play go and play
you've got to do this okay
you didn't read the tutorial i didn't i
super didn't
okay so you gotta yeah you're gonna okay
okay i see it's left right left trigger
right trigger over and over again
potentially maybe potentially
some kind of qte situation
oh my gosh pressure's on i you know i
have you watching me do this
i can't i could do this could you
in real life get the 60 points yeah i
can do if yeah i can do it
i'm not so good with my left i'm
actually left footed
who's left footed i am left-footed and
right-handed yeah i'm left-footed
oh that's the same as my best mate um
yeah he's right-handed and he's
left-footed yeah
this is actually like just
not even really engaging yeah but get
the points
yeah gotta get the points though in it
so i can 10 more spend them
uh get a cheeky sausage roll and that
go greg's go greg's i've heard about
greg
well i [ __ ] did it already so that's
um
you love soccer if i'm aren't you
wearing a soccer shirt right now
no okay sorry she's not uh apparently
it's not open which is [ __ ]
devastating also
does the aquarium just look like a
series of of
offices uh whatever it's fine
this kind of reminds me of melbourne
actually
and there's there's the london eye how
do you feel
you know i never compared london to
melbourne what a [ __ ] insult
you went to melbourne on bad terms i
think
i can hijack i was i was open to it
sure you were and it sucked it really is
no melbourne's pretty dark no it was
just we were there though
whether it could be a real [ __ ] winter
yeah it was just bad weather
my chat's saying melbourne is better so
oh then they're right um where do you
think aussies are from
a variety of places as a multicultural
country
okay yeah i'm literally the second
generation i can i could get a british
passport if i wanted i'm that close
little tunis we don't want more [ __ ]
immigrants
okay that's a lot to unpack coming from
you you should speak to a therapist i
think it's been coming from me
no nothing i'm not why coming because
you're
currently living in canada on a work
visa
yep and don't you otherwise live
in l.a
i've heard about these toilets troy was
telling me about
something about london toilets and that
they like pop up or something i don't
really
there's a couple of places i'm sure that
they yeah
come out the ground yeah yeah that's
what i think troy was saying
i've never i've never used one or seen
one it's crazy [ __ ]
i'm not the best tour guide i could just
tell you where i used to go for
auditions
i would love to give me a tour of where
you worked it went for an audition
called let's do it
all right so
hold on look at the map pull the map up
so i uh was that the bfm uh bfi imax
uh so i don't know if that shows up on
the phone
uh see that circle right there
bottom can you see that little dome here
no there you see that yeah
drive there there
stop yelling at me you stupid drones
okay i ain't got time for your [ __ ]
what's [ __ ] chat saying what's
[ __ ] chat saying
mostly comments on the time wow it's 4
27 a.m
is it really no it's wherever their time
zone is we haven't been streaming for
three hours
um two hours that would be uh what i
don't want any of this
no i've made a grave mistake yeah you
don't want to do that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh just no scuffed the knees
just barely scuffed them everything's
fine okay i need to get back
set away point i did but i i'm trying to
there's no motorbike
oh yeah i've seen a few future
motorbikes actually motorbike
or bust well i can't spawn a motorbike
that's a pretty nice car
um uh if i find one i will write it for
you but i don't know that i can just
spawn one
see look look things that you recognize
i've seen the londoner you just showed
me that tea and that i'm just trying to
make you happy
you know right i don't know i'm just
trying to bring up the things that make
you
where seruga
why couldn't they write oh roger oh
choppacino
spice chai frappe they i mean they got
pretty close these assets are low res
though can we talk about how low
resolution that is
sporty stuff all right full disclosure
ubisoft gave me access to this thank you
for probably providing me with the code
ubisoft i really appreciate it
you should have said that before i
started ripping on their waypoints and
well no that's the opposite because
you don't stop ripping on things because
you got provided access to the thing
you're still honest mate
that's not that's ethics if they had
sent me a rise of skywalker hoodie i
would have said it was the best
stalwarts movie i've ever seen
so easily so easily bought i will not
um is this the thing that exists
hologram chess
no brilliant we do have giant
chessboards
oddly everywhere in australia giant
giant chest
nice thanks i'm glad you noticed
i appreciate it where's he gone
it's that time of night in it well why
are you just mentoring on maine because
it's past 2 am
true i say all manner of [ __ ] now
i look i'm avoiding driving because i'm
oh that's gonna be a tank
because to the cops i think what
happened at the start of this game
there's a bike there's a bike there's
like
do we want that though yeah yeah yeah
moped we want a moped
stopped it stopped and it's right next
to the cops so
gone don't feel great about it i also
stole it from a mailman
which you know we're really trying to
protect out here right now
that's how uh you know um
letter got stolen from a parcel fox
did you not hear about that today i
haven't heard about that i haven't been
on social media
the last few days tucker carlson on fox
was like reports a story
they have this very important document
that exposes hunter biden or whatever
but then he details how it's been stolen
and now they've lost the only
copy of it convenient because email
doesn't exist they didn't make a copy
but we have the thing
and we can't confirm which company we
sent it to but we mailed it somewhere
and yeah it got
lost in the mail but look it happens
maybe this is what happens what i'm
saying
i've had some devastating things lost in
the mail i think i tweeted about this
i'm pretty sure i told you
um did you at the company no i don't do
that because i'm not a [ __ ] karen
like you mate
no no i i have there were like three
times where i had ordered bras
and uh never got them and i became
convinced that somebody
like in my building or nearby was
was stealing all my padded bras yeah
i was like do we have somebody who's
just [ __ ] stealing my laundry because
that's when we stream
of people complaining how inappropriate
i am i
uh i haven't i probably will after this
one um i have had people dm me and be
like hey
it's clear that the men that you stream
with really bully you and i'm like what
are you [ __ ] talking about and i
i did cuss one dude out because i was
like not only are you completely
misreading the situation but you're also
like trying to tell me that my own close
friends are terrible people
and i just not really a fan well it's
like
you know i i remember the beaver wax
thing you remember when we did
open house and i was like did you where
did you get your beaver wax and
the comments were like and you went yeah
dude super he went too far
he made her uncomfortable he's this and
it's like no you've projected all of
that i treated her the exact
same way i'd have treated um kovic or or
bruce at the time which
i've never heard you ask bruce if he
waxes his dick
not once have i heard you asking that so
i do i was talking about bruce
and bruce's dick and stuff do you know
that's true for the record i like i
think people being considerate i am okay
with but
um i also am very difficult to make
uncomfortable
and sometimes i wasn't trying to make
you uncomfortable no i know you weren't
you weren't trying to make me
uncomfortable you didn't make me
uncomfortable and if people read it that
way they're just wrong like if i were
uncomfortable
i don't even know what i do because i'm
so frequently
not uncomfortable i'm trying to find an
entrance to whatever the [ __ ] this is um
my point there is you didn't make me
uncomfortable and and people just kind
of tend to assume with that stuff which
is still good because you're a woman
because they're going nope
that's not how you talk to women no
that's how you talk to friends well if
we didn't know each other super well it
would be weird and
they don't know any of that i suppose um
what is this that i'm circling right now
bossman william what is it it would take
me to one in london
is it can you can you look how did you
bring up what it was
what stadium are we at does chat no
european processing center
oh no they've converted a stadium and
called it a european product it's a
text file or whatever that is yeah i
mean it certainly looks like a
farco stadium i i want to find the south
bank i want to show you
we do bfm bfi imax okay where's the bfi
imax it seems like it goes hard
what's that station what's that go to
the london underground signs
you see the london underground signs
they look like the ghostbuster signs
line through the circle that's the troop
station this
hover on the left
this the thing that i'm on right now
can't be more clear than that
the symbol the icon that's looks like
the ghostbusters symbol a circle with a
line straight you're telling me this
me this [ __ ] no no keep going you'll
notice it's right this one
london underground symbol that tells you
what station is there
riverside okay so what's
kind across there the net look for each
one of those and it gives us an idea of
where we are because
lambeth palace what is this it looks
like it's in [ __ ] world of warcraft
pidge i'm just gonna walk over here real
quick
okay you see i want to look at whatever
this this is a fantasy [ __ ] is okay
don't mind me somebody in chat said why
this game looks like it came out in 2010
it could be like my stream settings but
i feel like this game looks pretty good
it is an open world game that actually i
think feels more like gta
5 than anything else that has come out
since gta 5.
lambeth palace is almost 800 year old
rahul didn't tell me that i should just
get
chat to give me a [ __ ] tour not real
apparently it is yeah seems like it is
also somebody said this chat is
perfectly splendid
it's perfectly splendid
bike yeah but look at it though
this place is beautiful no it's not it
looks like every other piece of [ __ ]
building in london
i'm so used to exotic architecture that
everything looks like a piece of [ __ ] to
me
that's how you sound
it's a reminder of white oppression wow
that he took a stance on that one i'm
sorry that i'm sorry that i'm not
interested
now you feel bad isn't it no no i
no i'm good where are we going
southbank sasebank all right hold on
i'm gonna find it stay there you are
[ __ ] terrible at this rahul covey
imax oh my gosh why the imax there's so
many things in london that you could
take me to and you're like
well we went to a [ __ ] imax mate wait
go to the
highlight the london eye
i'm taking you to the national fair
tower oh okay
uh where is the london eye here
here zoom please
zoomed ah okay now move
your stick yes uh to the next bridge
that's
under the fog so that would be like
northeast
what yeah there okay okay
cool now you see that follow that down
uh click there click here on that area
there
yeah we're going there that's where the
bfi imax is that's where the national
theatre is and that's one of the places
i did a play
you done did a play i did yeah
i am an actor oh my god so many women
have just gone into slid into my dms oh
this is exhausting it's so exhausting
being an actor oh my gosh
ever since like the first oh
no i'm just i'm an actor in it do you
know what i mean like talk about my
performance talk about my costume
talk about my screen presence just stop
talking about how hard i am all the time
god gets
sick oh i don't want to see pictures of
your vaginas
why do they have more than one does each
individual woman have multiple vaginas
that's exciting okay it's an option i
feel like there are probably
have you seen the dude who just posted
on reddit who's got what do you want to
make something
i didn't do it i just glossed over it um
the dude who's got the dude who posted
on reddit who's got two dicks and they
can both come so he's had threesomes
where he's having sex with both chicks
at once
true he comes out of both dicks no
that's not true
yes it is there's a guy who's got two
giants yeah there's a two who has two
dicks i said a two'd
all right so i'm at the location you
told me to come to boston
whoa all right who's done that
what the [ __ ]
yeesh okay map
um to the right of that is the national
theatre
this can be this no yeah that big
building there no
this one that's that's rectangular
building
this one lower closer to the water yeah
so try and get to that side that's
uh then i probably need to just find a
way to get sort of through this yeah
all right
is this what you envisioned the road no
i'm not
now you're on the right side yeah you
are a full second behind me so your
feedback is delayed
okay this should be the background of
this cinema
that's pretty cool who's this whole
[ __ ] she's just chilling
okay queen
it actually it actually might be you
know that is the queen
why is she gone rave glasses on
what have they done to her unbelievable
okay that's queen victoria
is this your [ __ ] theater that's i
think that's the national theater
you played at the theater that's this
cool you
it's the national yes at a legit theater
yeah how much did you pay them i was
i played an extra in a play for three
months that's how that's where i was
what's that kind of job like
i was i just played an afghan war
majadeen and i just shout allahu akbar
at the end of the play
is that true 100 sure wow
for three months and if you find the
book of the play because it was the
first time the play was just was
the was performed i'm in the book
you're in a book we have a published
actor
when the play comes out after it's been
on stage
they write the first cast that ever
played in it they write their names and
under the under the extras
it says royal cody that's pretty cute do
you still have it
no i couldn't give flying [ __ ] brilliant
then why'd you just tell the story in
front of
about 4 500 people because we're outside
the theater you can
i don't know that i deserve that one
i'm trying to get to the front of it
yeah the the
imax is around here as well i don't know
i get yeah this imax better be [ __ ]
lit for how much you're talking about
it's just a giant dime on a roundabout
oh that is actually pretty cool really i
think this yeah to go to the back
entrance
and my little raffle keep going good day
bro this is the way i walk when i go to
uh be a [ __ ] extra in that
oh go to the water yeah i am right i'm
just sort of a [ __ ]
this is south bank how cool is that yeah
obviously oh this is pretty
we don't have all of this crap there
well yeah
future things
okay if i walk to try to make london
look like blade runner
i like it i like the aesthetic
it's normal hashtag not my city
yeah that's it that's national
i feel like from those balconies
the balconies oh yeah i see yeah there's
balconies there yeah
i feel like if i didn't you know if it
didn't have all this [ __ ] trash
everywhere
i would think this was quite beautiful
it's pretty cool
i imagine this is is it is it a nice
area what's that
it's very nice what's that over there do
you know what that is
no i think that's st paul's cathedral
wouldn't it
look you got so british just then um
looks like a cathedral
your proper testing my knowledge it
reminds me of mary poppins i think
that's saint paul's is chat did the chat
say i was right they did
someone said it's the white house that
seems like it might not be true so
i wish i might be in the wrong place
yeah this is uh this is that is this
bridge yeah let's let's [ __ ] get on
the walking bridge
go to st falls
there's no game set in brisbane
australia let me tell you
i think i i'm sorry 2010.
that how's the last time so i've been
there in
20 in 10 years oh this is the tape it
says tate modern
what is it says this this whatever this
building is
also says tate modern which you think is
a thing you were mentioning before were
you not
i just been gushing over the national
when it wasn't even the right building
no that's the other one was the national
this one is
i don't know am i wrong what are you
facing what are you calling the tate
it said on here tate national
what does chat say
um i think the chat is saying that you
are wrong and this is the tate yes
no that's the national oh maybe they're
right
so you you said you worked here and you
smoked on these words yeah
yeah but it looks like the national
unless i mean i told you i haven't been
there in 10 years look to the left
you're the worst at this the chat said
it is definitely not the national
so what are the tape nationals on the
other side of the river went with the
national before i thought that's where
we were
where that the square was
i feel like i know this [ __ ] place
better than you do you goddamn
embarrassing brit
jesus anyway we're going to saint paul's
cathedral which you were correct about
[ __ ] i think you just spoke so loudly
that discord muted you what did you say
that was the national theater that was
south bank well you're wrong
so it says the tape on it
it does look it doesn't the chad is also
saying i'm right the national was it at
the the square we were at first at
trafalgar no that's not the national
theatre
it said that was the national national
gallery i'm talking about the national
theatre
okay okay that makes sense two different
things
this is 100 motherless
[ __ ] all right i'll show you tate
modern mate it
yep apparently the national problem
because the nationals right there look
like we were just there but it is
there's the bridge out of settings
and and there's the national fair it's
the same look i think
we've got to be looking at it how about
is this the national that's the atrium
yeah what's this that's too close
if you said you're at the atrium county
hall jubilee gardens
the gardens are next to it and then
you're going over to another bridge
right what have you got there again this
is
not they think that you are one bridge
off
because of course the map is not
perfectly to scale you know it's
like a ubisoft map little move stuff
drops you're saying i'm one
bridge off yeah which i again i think is
i'm typing in tate this it literally
says when i go to the building we were
just at
tate modern for sure
okay so they've messed this up they've
cut the national out so
i don't know if you can see so the
london eye
so that this is what's happening okay
okay yeah so
yeah all right all right so we were at
the london eye oh god this is hard
because you've got me reversed
discord's done that right yes yeah okay
so
focus come on yeah yeah ah you see the
london eye
you see it there london eye no it says
london eye right there
i see tate modern on there yeah yeah
yeah yeah but that's the london eye
okay right there that's the see ah i
see what you're saying yeah you're right
that that bend looks like that on your
map
so maybe there is no national yeah they
squeezed it because the tape
and that london eye are way further
apart and in between that is
so they've condensed it i think unless
that gray area there that foggy
is it possible that this thing
because it sounds like atrium is the
theater
that might be it no but it's not that
close to the london eye oh yeah but it's
a condensed map
right so okay here's what we're gonna do
i'm gonna go [ __ ] look at the stupid
cathedral
and then i'm gonna come back i just told
the imax go back to the map i just saw
the imax [ __ ] it now
all right go back to the fog you see
that roundabout cylinder thing there
this is your imax that's the imax click
that
okay and then then the nationals there
that's this one
the south bank atrium all right we'll
come back around no no no no it's not
the south pacific
just go to the imax
i want to watch a nolan film i want to
see dunkirk
i would like to see dunkirk
i'm trying to think of other things
there's somebody at the door other
things that
matt berry says now hold on there sugar
tits
yes i can hear you clem fandango
brilliant all right cool this is
this [ __ ] big yeah oh yeah that's
saint paul's cathedral i love it
hello jen hello jen
what some chav [ __ ]
just said words to me all right so this
is uh is
what it looks like it's important
cathedral yeah
it's not the uh bfo bfi max
[ __ ] you know all right okay we're going
to the bfi max because
we could go to anything here and he just
wants to go to [ __ ] watch a film
ridiculous ridiculous
you're right yeah
should i steal this car yeah
i think i might do it
okay jacket well there's nobody in it
that's the slang we use was this
exactly project right okay allow it
okay i'm i'm dusting [ __ ] ambulance
don't hit them
the um cars all do handle differently
happy to report so that's tight
happy to see that here we go are you
ready to the imax
i'm so [ __ ] excited to see an imax
tourist there are so many landmarks here
we
could have gone to london bridge no he's
just [ __ ] let's go to the oven
and then i'll take you to the nearest
game video game shop
and where i used to buy my model kits i
asked for the nandos
there it is okay that's actually pretty
dope coley
that's the bfi imax that's actually
like pretty cool so i would walk is it
annoying to get into though
no no no you go you you go on a tunnel
really yeah cool and that's that's the
imax it's one of the first
oh wait so you can't even enter it from
the street you have to enter it by a
tunnel
yeah because you're on the road dude
that's sick
i'm sorry for how little faith i had in
your
eye right in the center and then a movie
poster will wrap around that
that is actually really correct so i
used to walk i did a post about this
so i used to walk past that when i was
an extra in a play every day and i was
making 17 pounds
per show for three hours and my agent at
the time was taking commission
um off my 17 pounds but i was 17 pounds
for three hours doesn't seem that bad
depending on how old is 17 pounds not
for three hours it was longer actually
but it was 17 pounds a show
17 not 70 one seven
it was like five pounds what's that
conversion rate no it wasn't even five
pounds now i wasn't there for three
hours i'd get there at seven i wouldn't
finish until
eleven figure out four hours seventeen
pounds
to usd
nope that is bad yep yeah and i was
getting that for four hours
and then my manager at the time my agent
was taking 20 of that
yikes that's so rude to get there on the
train
cost me about 11 quid
so that's what i was doing hey worked
out pretty well for you
well every day i walked past that imax
and would look at it and i'd be like one
day
one day i'm gonna go and i can pay you
to watch a film there
[Laughter]
one day i'm gonna be on that still
hasn't done it and then when girls five
came out last year
the gears five poster was on there was
fives on it
no that don't take it away from me sorry
i didn't i thought you were gonna say
yes was on there
and that was just the moment it was like
yeah that's super dope it's a shame you
couldn't be there to see it but that is
extreme yeah and it's the shame files
wasn't on it but i was entitled times
square
yes i saw that that's cool um
hang on i'm gonna try and find this
stupid this is going to be your theater
we think
yeah they're there the grayed out no
just [ __ ]
so lippy this one you reckon
this one okay
all right see if this is your real
theater and not the tate you [ __ ]
fraud of a man
i was like look at it trending the
boards i'll never forget this place
file the nuclear weapons i was looking
at the tape the whole time going you
were yeah
memories of a building that is not the
one i
intended is this gonna take me on the
bridge day
i should be going on the bridge i don't
feel like i want to go on the bridge
you won't go on the bridge you won't go
on the bridge side step it to the right
side to the right to the right to the
right right on there
okay is this the pathway that you
thought you were actually walking on
when we were at the table
with the alley way through that everyone
saw
remember i said i went through an
alleyway you did this was so i would go
around this side of the roundabout
and go straight down here and then i'd
hook a right
a cool bike
ride it yeah my pony
um your chick's got a bit of baby she
does actually
yeah i think she's she's a bit hot um
didn't say that oh wow i'm saying it
okay this will look looks a lot more
like a theater
the macbeth yeah it says william
shakespeare
that's the balcony smoke that is the
balcony
this is a lot smaller than the other
building i wait it's way smaller
that's not to scale because i feel like
the national was way bigger than that
this says it's just called british
theater yeah
this is definitely the right one yeah we
figured it out we've solved the mystery
um it's pretty embarrassing for you but
i'm not for me
so oh which is the third oh let's go see
richard the third
now is the winter of our discontent made
glorious summer by this this is why you
shouldn't be friends with actors people
i don't recommend that it's disgusting
actually it makes me sick to my stomach
so
tell us more about when you went to
france with media molecules you come i
went to france
actually media molecule is actually
a british studio exactly [ __ ] to see
quantic dream
oh yeah you're right heavy rain yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i went for detroit
become human
i went to paris games week once too um
we had one other stop that we wanted to
check out before we wrap it up did we
not
there was one other place you wanted me
to go
all right so red light district all
right where's that
soho that's a bit of a trek people are
saying the game shop where's the game
shop mate
we could also go to chelsea stadium
that's uh you could go to i would go to
where did i buy games sometimes if i was
doing an audition i'd go to hmv on
oxford street
um
what's worth seeing what's a good
landmark you saw
trafalgar square piccadilly is always a
good place to leave it we should go to
piccadilly okay where's piccadilly
north north it's back across the bridge
okay zoom in right it's hard to without
i don't i can't read maps like that
because i'm not rain man
um what stations are highlighted so at
least we can have some bearings
fine some you know the symbol now for
the london underground
yes we've got [ __ ] you stuck in
houston here
yeah houston station and that's it
because everything else is fog
oh you can fast travel what's it no no
there's three there
yeah right there
no no get further into the city away
from the thames good
street no
that's huge oh that's near leicester
square hold on
there's piccadilly right there so uh go
back to googe
oh it literally says this is piccadilly
yeah yeah piccadilly circus i was gonna
say
yeah yeah i did lose the cool bike
though
that's bummer oh you need to i think
you'll be able to anyway gotcha
but that you know piccadilly's got the
the big uh
like neon sign sanyo i am vaguely
familiar
if you play cod obviously it's a little
level
and i live on the piccadilly line where
i used to i grew up on the pixelate line
so i used to do a lot of my
auditions i would come out of this
station here just like this
that's exactly where i'd come out from
uh no i'd come out from
all right well then why'd you say it was
that one because i couldn't tell from
any
uh steps that i'd be on the other side
but
i'll show you where i okay there there's
this is piccadilly circus so
look at look up all these this lights up
is this like um london's equivalent of
times square
yeah archer i see star version but this
is also a map in cod
uh if you head right
yeah uh oh so down there you see where
that newsstand is
yep a lot of auditions were down there
in this direction yeah yeah and there's
like
there was a coffee shop there there's a
burger king there you reckon they have
cheeky nando's around here though
i think there is a nando's nearby where
i used to go to a place called wasabi
um and it was a sushi place that did an
amazing
uh katsu curry i would always get that
after an audition because it was a treat
because i didn't have one near my area
just looking at this stuff is making me
really miss traveling dear god
uh this is uh this would be um
bond street no not bond street
is it bond street i don't know you can
do b don't trust you anymore your barons
court
oh what the [ __ ] is it hold on bond
street is it bond
let's pick italy what's chat say
regent street region so it's region it's
piccazilli
region one begins with b
bond is the rich one is what jamie
somebody said yeah
yeah the rich one there's one of these
is bond street and then you go down
there
i can check if we have street signs well
you have um
oh you didn't shout bus wankers they
were bus wankers boss
well wankers know they're gone now no i
was talking to you
uh i feel like this is bond street isn't
it
it looks fancy yeah go down it
look at this old man
ah food center yes we're near mayfair
i'm pretty sure which you'll know from
your monopoly board
that's um again just the narcissism
rahul kohli
no what australians play australian
monopoly
with australian locations
you know sheila's place was some [ __ ]
yeah no all of them yeah
no we yeah ramsay street
nice good reference good [ __ ]
um all right shall we wrap it up are we
do you feel like you've sufficiently
shown me london are you homesick and
that
i think you've got it all now yeah i
don't i don't need to go back
oh i didn't quite expect that stance i'm
just going to end up in
in this park here because it seems like
it can you hit someone
what was that i just hit a [ __ ] for you
oh keep going keep going
oh okay slap the [ __ ] out of them no i'm
getting it nope i'm getting in trouble
oh somebody's got a drone scene to me
what's he going to do he's going to
shoot me i don't even know i could hack
it you only punch someone
it's you know it's not america you
shouldn't get shot for
for hitting someone i wonder if they
they make that change honestly because
in san francisco on the left i didn't
like his bag
his bag no it's on the right boss man
yeah yeah smack him i don't like those
stupid pull string bags
you go oh you went down quick oh that
did not take long
i think i might have killed him i think
he might have killed him you know
well um no don't don't walk over here
[ __ ] you didn't see
[ __ ] they might have well oh no i gotta
beat this [ __ ]
oh jesus these [ __ ] brits oh she
knows
well she was actually she was blocking
me someone's gotta
fight you back that guy looks like he's
tasty
are you gonna fight me yeah yeah yeah
this guy looks like he's tasty no he's
just
he's just going for a stroll let's do
this dude
you look like you could fight um
look at his shirt though for some reason
i kicked him in no one's pointing back
and um blood came out so when you've got
a gas mask
on yep i don't know why that's happened
how about you
come off come on he whipped out from one
no he's actually he's still up call him
he's a lawyer
hey yo puss yo come here blood what
phone you got
his name is michael cohen
i'm talking to you come here [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] blood come here
i like it i should but i like it
yeah this we just
do you know how i know that yeah it's
not because i was a road man it's
because i've been mugged three times and
that's
amazing so i'm i'm really glad that we
ended this by giving everyone the
authentic london experience of people
getting beat the [ __ ] out on the street
it's just a shame i didn't have a knife
elf fascio bro
[ __ ] old blood i don't even know
what he's i don't even know is this
english anymore i don't even know it's
like three in the morning and i
have to be up in yep all right bye
everyone thanks for joining